(light music)
- I guess there's a certain part of me
that's always thought that
computer parts look like cities.
My name is Zayd Menk.
I'm an 18-year-old
artist from Zimbabwe.
(bright music)
I grew up in a family of nine people.
My parents had a repurposing
attitude towards most things.
How can we use the rubbish
to make something else?
So, I just make my artwork
out of the things that I find
and the things that I collect.
I grew up in Harare, the
capital city of Zimbabwe,
and I really like it there.
But we do have quite a few challenges,
like political unrest
and economic challenges.
There's also e-waste dumping
that has affected many
of the poorer areas around the city.
This project that I'm working on
is a collaboration with HPE
to make an area of Westminster
done in recycled electronics.
I think what I'm doing on a small scale
is basically what they
doing on a large scale
in a slightly different way.
The parts for this project
were from HPE's facility.
It was quite different,
compared to what happened
for my first project.
With that one, I had to go
around asking friends and family
and trying to scavenge things
from the side of the road.
When planning for this project,
I used a lot of online
resources to calculate
what area I'm going to do.
It was also quite helpful
to see things in person.
It puts things in
perspective quite nicely.
From there I sketch out
the layout of the city,
and I just start building
the individual buildings
one by one.
I think, in a perfect world,
there wouldn't be such a thing as waste.
Everything would be reused
and repurposed for something else.
- There are about fifty million
tons of e-waste generated
on an annual basis.
And substances that go into the products
have impacts to soil, water, human health.
We can't just take, make, dispose anymore.
We need to really think
about how we responsibly
design, manufacture, and
dispose of the products,
or potentially reuse them
at their end of life.
The circular economy is a shift from
the traditional linear economy.
Into a model where it's
regenerative in nature.
One of the most exciting aspects
of our environmental program
are our technology renewal centers.
Of the material that comes in the door,
over 89 percent
is actually refurbished,
remarketed and sold to new customers.
The remaining portion is
recycled in a responsible way
to have real impact at scale.
- In the future, if
companies embrace the idea
of the circular economy,
e-waste might not be an issue.
And my artwork might be
seen as a sort of weird,
historical artifact from a time
when we didn't know any better.
(mellow music)